okay so it's a it's a symbol that
doesn't actually get used that much um
which is an r with a little cross with a
circle around it after it as a suffix at
the bottom of the the symbol um and the
r is for radius and the cross with the
circle around it is this astrological
symbol for the earth um and so it's the
radius of the earth it's the symbol yeah
it's kind of in the news again now i
mean you know the radius of the earth is
sort of fairly mundane well-known
quantity but it's become a big issue
again because people have started
discovering all these planets outside
the solar system and obviously the big
question that everyone wants answered is
are they like the earth
and so one of the simplest measurements
that you can make is to measure the
radius of them and say well if the
radius is kind of you know maybe one or
two times the radius of the earth then
that's a planet that's earth-like
whereas if it's say 10 times the radius
of the earth
that's the radius of jupiter for example
so that's a jupiter-like planet so it's
not like the earth so it's really a way
of measuring whether a planet's like the
earth or not by measuring its radius in
earth radii i mean the whole field of of
looking at planets outside the solar
system has exploded you know it's really
only in the last 15 years that we've
found any planets outside the solar
system at all and now we're up around
four or five hundred planets known
outside the solar system but the reason
why it's a big story at the moment is a
new satellite has gone up a telescope
called kepler and kepler's whole job is
to try and find more and more of these
exoplanets
and they've just released their first
results the telescope's been up there
for more than a year now but they've
actually just released their first
results and they found about about five
planets just from the it was sort of the
first six weeks of data they looked at
and they're already rumors that there
are many more planets in there as well
it uses a technique um called
occultations
and the basic idea is that if you happen
to have a a system where you've got a
star and a planet orbiting around it and
it happens to be exactly edge on then
every time that the planet goes around
the planet comes between you and the
star now the planet's a lot smaller than
the star so it doesn't block out all the
light of the star but it blocks out a
little bit of the light of the star and
so some tiny fraction of a percentage of
the light 0.1.01 percent of the light of
the star gets blocked out by the passage
of the planet in front of it and this
telescope is so sensitive that it can
actually measure those tiny little dips
now it's a little more complicated than
that because there are lots of things
that can make stars vary the sun's
output there is a bit when there's a
solar flare it gets a bit brighter and
so on so there's lots of ways that stars
can get brighter and dimmer but if you
see this characteristic signature of the
signal dipping in a periodic fashion so
regularly uh every time that the
something orbits around it then you've
really got a pretty strong indication
that there is actually a planet in orbit
around so the neat thing about this
technique is it's actually one of the
few techniques you can actually use to
measure the radius of a planet because
of course the amount of light that gets
blocked out depends on how big the
planet actually is big planets block out
more of the light little planets block
out less of the light and so you can
actually get a pretty reliable
measurement as to how big these planets
actually are
and they're now finally getting down to
the sizes of planets that really are
kind of comparable to the earth so the
smallest that they found uh is about
four times the radius of the earth so
you really are getting down to now
fairly earth-like planets still a bit
bigger than the earth but really getting
to that sort of size
it's i mean it's not a particularly
well-defined quantity for example do you
measure to the lowest point on earth
which is the bottom of the pacific ocean
somewhere do you measure to the highest
point on earth top of a mountain
somewhere uh do you measure to sea level
uh and of course the the earth isn't
exactly round because it's rotating it
actually ends up bulging out a bit in
the equator um so it's about 30 or 40
kilometers bigger at the equator than it
is at the poles it's a bit squashed um
and so there's lots of different
measurements you can make you can make
but in terms of actually you know
comparing the size of the earth to other
things it really doesn't matter that
much all you really need to know is the
radius of the earth is a little less
than six thousand four hundred
kilometers does that mean that earth
radius is a bit like the way journalists
use olympic-sized swimming pools or
double decker buses and football fields
it's just to help give an idea of scale
exactly it's a way of just measuring the
size of things and it's you know it's a
useful thing
partly because it's something that sort
of people can slightly relate to but
also because lying behind it there is
this question is this a planet like the
earth and so measuring something in
earth radii gives you an immediate
feeling you know it's four times the
radius of the earth so it's not quite
like the earth but it's not that
different from the earth or it's 20
times the radius of the earth then it's
really not very like the earth at all
does something have to be similar to the
size of the earth to have earth-like
conditions
that's not really clear i mean the what
the problem is there are lots of things
that go into you know whether a planet
ends up like the earth like you know how
close it is to its star so whether water
is liquid those kinds of things one of
the important things is what the gravity
is because obviously if the pull of
gravity was 10 times what it is on the
earth then things would be a lot more
squashed if the polar gravity is a lot
less then there's you know the less to
hold things onto the surface so for an
earth-like planet you probably want the
pull of gravity to be comparable to the
earth and so one way of doing that if
something is the same density as the
earth if you want the pull of gravity to
be the same then it really has to be
more or less the same size now one of
the interesting things about these
planets that are just being discovered
with the kepler satellite is they're not
all comparable in density to the earth
there's this ridiculous planet out there
which actually has a density that's sort
of comparable to styrofoam incredibly
low density planet
so actually you could end up with
earth-like gravity on a planet which is
a completely different size from the
earth so in the light of these new
discoveries we may actually have to kind
of change our views a bit about what
planets really are earth like
no it's not a new question at all people
have worried about it i mean ever since
basically ever since you started
thinking the earth might be round then
the obvious question to ask is well if
it's round was his radius um and so the
first sort of scientific attempt to
measure the radius of the earth was made
by a greek guy eratosthenes about 200 bc
and uh he came up with this very clever
he's amazing guy he was an athlete he
was interested in geography he was
interested in astronomy mathematics so
cause sort of the amazing wide range of
things he did but one of the things he
did just along the way was measured the
size of the earth and the way he did it
was very clever um essentially he looked
at how high the sun was in the sky where
he lived and then went a few hundred
miles north and measured on the same on
the same day at the same time or got a
friend to do it because obviously you
couldn't get there instantly to measure
how far how high the sun was in the sky
on the same day and of course as you go
around the surface of the earth you know
if the sun's overhead in one place if
you go north the sun's no longer
overhead it's a bit sort of lower in the
sky
and so you can actually figure out
in going these few hundred miles what
fraction of the circumference of the
earth he'd actually gone around and
since he knew the circumference was you
know two pi times the radius once he'd
figured out what fraction of the
circumference he'd gone around he could
figure out what the whole circumference
was um and hence figure out what the
radius of the earth was and he actually
got an answer that was right to within a
few percent by making that measurement
and that was the kind of the the classic
measurement of the the radius of the
earth for centuries afterwards